foreign
[Music]
exhibition Hall a vision of the future
we're going to have autonomous driving
we're going to have much smarter
infrastructure of digital engineering
and of Finance today we'll be talking
about uh Central Bank digital currencies
and a new language of business web 3
blockchain decentralized ecosystem
tomato is a play to earn coin on the
ethereum blockchain this is the world of
cryptocurrencies and blockchain
Innovation some believe Will Change the
World by digitizing human transactions
but there is a bug in this vision of
digital Nirvana
2022 has seen collapsing crypto values
and bankruptcies culminating in the
biggest collapse of all FTX the trading
platform accused of one of the largest
frauds in U.S financial history
the mainstream face of cryptocurrency
extradited from the Bahamas to the U.S
accused of massive embezzlement perhaps
dragon cryptocurrency with him it's a
fall from grace almost as rapid as the
rise of a young man who built a billion
dollar fortune and profile to match from
almost nowhere
he was raised on the Stanford campus he
went to MIT yet parents that were
tenured professors at the Stanford Law
School uh he had gone under Gene Street
and even though he had a corpus to him
or a nerdiness to him I think people
found him relatively engaging and found
him to be
um
a a a an upfront sort of guy bankman
freed known universally as SPF made his
first Fortune from winning bets on
bitcoin and his second from founding FDX
the trading platform he said existed to
fund his altruism do you have a sense of
how much you've given away so far it's a
bit north of 100 million so far this
year
but FDX was lavishly marketed with
celebrity Laden advertising in prime
time Super Bowl slots
you expect this court to do its business
inside we're like animals we go outside
like humans it's FTX it's a safe and
easy way to get into crypto
yeah I don't think so and I'm never
wrong about this stuff personal
endorsements from the likes of
supermodels Gisele
and policy activism that Drew presidents
and prime ministers to a Bahamas
conference this year that seemed to
affirm SBS rise
[Music]
it was a profile and a platform built on
the promise of crypto
but what exactly is that worth
[Music]
to understand we need to go back to
basics
to the bank of England a place that's
been defining value for more than 300
years for centuries currencies have
derived their value from the backing of
central banks that used to come from
gold held in the vaults here but in the
age of paper money or polymer like this
tenor it comes from this the signature
of someone who works in this building
printed on every note that says the bank
is good for the number that's written on
the other side crypto wants to do away
with all of that the bank the notes the
people and digitize everything including
Trust
[Music]
it's an ambition that has its roots in
the 2008 financial crisis and the
banking system failed and an alternative
Manifesto for money was born promising
to remove intermediaries from Financial
Exchange
the first cryptocurrency Bitcoin
[Music]
14 years on there are hundreds of coins
and in place of presses and mints a
growing infrastructure of electronic
mining mining rigs down here plug
sockets infrastructure test units and
Rack Em Up stack them up Josh runs a
thriving business making and marketing
mining rigs in the Northwest in order
for all this crypto to move around so if
I were to send one coin from my wallet
to your wallet it takes off special
computers in the middle to make that
transaction happen so we make those
special computers and if you own those
computers you're able to get a little
bit of that coin a financial reward as a
thank you for providing that power to
move the coins around think of each of
these boxes as an electronic pickaxe
competing to chip coins from the data
depths one of the really interesting
things with with cryptocurrency in
general particularly the minable coins
is that most of them have what's called
a difficulty algorithm so in a nutshell
the more people mining or the more
physical machines trying to mine the
coins the harder that mathematical
algorithm gets so the same amount of
coins are split across more people and
it just gets harder and underlying it
all is a developing technology known as
blockchain that may be the most perhaps
the only truly valuable element of
crypto
each cryptocurrency transaction is
recorded on a block that is added to a
chain in what's called a distributed
digital Ledger each block contains
details of the new transaction and the
previous ones mean it can't be falsified
without changing every other previous
link and because every computer
transacting in a cryptocurrency is also
monitoring it they make up a powerful
public network overseeing the blockchain
instead of a single Central Authority or
middlemen
that technology has enabled vast sums to
be made and lost in crypto
but that growth poses a challenge to
Regulators like Sir John cunliffe Deputy
Governor of the bank of England
there's a lot of activity that's
developed over the last uh 10 years on
the trading and sale of crypto assets
assets without any intrinsic value so
the incredibly volatile and all of that
has grown up outside of outside of
Regulation some people say they're the
new gold you know they are the safest
thing they've gone the other way they've
been the most volatile thing they've
lost the most value in that sense so do
they have a future as a safer form of
money than that produced by kind of
central banks and the financial system
no I don't think so
in early November the volatility caught
up with SPF questions about the solvency
of his crypto hedge fund Alameda Capital
prompted A Rush of custom withdrawals
from FTX which didn't have the money to
cover them the exchange was Frozen as
Bachmann freed explored a sale to rival
exchange binance Anthony scaramucci a
business partner who would lose 10
million dollars flew to the Bahamas to
see Bachmann freed and his father I
thought I was going down there for a
rescue Finance Mission you know when I
talked to Professor Joe bankman it
seemed like there was an asset eye
ability mismatch between short-term
liabilities and long-term assets when I
got to the Bahamas the hall was deeper
and it was originally said to me they
then said that they were working with CZ
from binance and that he had signed a
non-binding term sheet but it wasn't
until some of the compliance people
and he asked me to step out of the room
and they had said to me listen uh uh in
direct violation of the terms of service
money was moved from accounts over to
Alameda which was Sam's personal account
uh and and somebody asked me for advice
on what to do I said listen you have to
tell the truth and then with great
sadness I had a conversation with
professor bankman and you could just see
the anguish on his face that his son was
obviously involved with something that
was at that time we didn't know but was
borderline on criminality and potential
fraud
that alleged fraud reaches beyond the
Bahamas to the heart of London's legal
district and tens of thousands of
investors believed to be in the UK
Louise Abba to crypto Ford specialist
represents dozens of them including an
investor with 5 million pounds of life
savings tied up in FTX that particular
investor has lost her whole life savings
so uh you know almost in tears down the
phone completely at a loss obviously
feels that they shouldn't have put that
size investment on onto white into into
one basket I suppose
um but at the same time didn't question
didn't question that that wasn't safe
people felt they were investing in a
mainstream Financial product did they
they did and they were it was a
mainstream Financial product that it
it's not a bogus platform it's genuine
um also it seems and it would have been
very very difficult or impossible for
investors to have known what was going
to happen
because I was
while ftx's investors wait for their
money the collapse has not knocked the
optimism of crypto entrepreneurs we
raised 19 million in seven and a half
weeks so we beat ethereum's Ico which
was absolutely insane 19 million dollars
yeah yeah how do you persuade me that I
can trust it because trust is the issue
in crypto right yeah and that's it so we
have I'm fully docked right so fully
docs means you can find out where I am
you know who I am it's very easy to
track me down we have a lot of people in
crypto who aren't fully docs and that's
where the scary guys come in what coins
keep coming the trading exchanges that
facilitate speculation say they will
learn lessons we're of course
shocked and need to react quickly to
make sure to assure the industry and
assure our users that you know the same
thing isn't going to happen to us so I
do think that there's more and more
regular regulation for these centralized
exchanges that are controlling lots of
people's money there's you know there
needs to be more transparency in the
industry about that but while new
entrance ride the spec relative waves of
crypto big business is embracing the
underlying technology
China barely 15 years old he's a teenage
technology so you get a sense in here of
how far they've come this place is full
of companies looking to exploit their
potential and it's not just startups
there are blue chip corporations already
deeply invested whatever the future
might look like they want a slice of it
blockchain for us is a good opportunity
to actually partner up with with all our
suppliers and also offer a good
possibility to share data across the
board in a safe and privacy preserving
way we've already done our first
blockchain system we call it the digital
asset broker and that enables vehicles
and electric vehicle charging points to
actually transact amongst themselves
we've been looking into blockchain
problem for the last seven years and
we've done multiple projects within
iterator we issued Bonds on the
blockchain
crypto's demanding attention in the city
too as institutional investors ask their
Banks to offer access to an estimated
trillion dollars in new digital assets
We Believe digital assets are here to
stay for the long term the primary job
for our Bankers to provide services to
the clients where they need it we're
slowly beginning to see large asset
managers talking about crypto assets
being part of the Arsenal for their
clients to utilize it's in two flavors
one is either an exchange traded product
or an outright trade into the crypto
asset for crypto and its technology to
mature requires regulation the bank of
England is considering how to make it
safer both for investors and The Wider
Financial system this crypto trading of
crypto assets was not big enough to
destabilize the financial system but it
was starting to develop links with the
financial system I don't know how that
will develop but we had Banks and
investment funds and others who wanted
to invest in it and I think we should
think about regulation before it becomes
integrated with the financial system and
before we could have a potential
systemic problem I don't think it will
be possible to say this can be just kept
outside of the financial system it's too
dangerous there is another step the bank
is considering a digital Central Bank
currency that could one day replace cash
there would be a digital equivalent of
the I promise to pay the bearer which in
the end underpins confidence
in money in the UK and we want to ensure
that as physical cash becomes less
usable in many parts of the economy
perhaps we need to offer something
digitally to provide that underpinning
Sam backman freed faces decades in jail
if convicted of defrauding investors out
of billions of dollars by using fdx's
customers money to cover bad trades by
his hedge fund money laundering and
breaking the law were making millions of
dollars in political donations
the chief executive handling fdx's
bankruptcy says there was nothing new
about the fraud this is really
old-fashioned in embezzlement this is
just taking money from customers
and using it for your own purpose not
sophisticated at all
because investors count their losses the
collapse of FDX and its front man has
exposed the dangers of this new frontier
crypto is often referred to as the wild
west of the financial world and this is
just an example of exactly what can
happen and risks remain I don't think
there's a sustainable Financial system
built around things that can lose half
their value in a day or or increase
healthy value
a sound back with free contemplates life
Behind Bars crypto faces its own
Reckoning new technologies they bring
out charltons and fraudsters it does not
mean that the new technology is going
away but what it does mean is that we
need the regulators
a technology designed to beat the
mainstream Financial system may need
that same system to finally lend their
credibility